Thanksgivings coming up and I invite you
guys to partake in the family tradition
that me and my family do every year and
no it does not involve standing outside
a store freezing your nuts off on the
day after Thanksgiving planes trains and
automobiles so every Thanksgiving my
family and I crack out the planes trains
and automobiles DVD and we laugh a lot
Steve Martin's a very financially
wealthy proper business type you know a
private person wife kids perfect life
big house basic white color guy before
you know the recession and the late
great John Candy is the exact opposite
of that in every way shape form and
shape so the planes are snowed in he's
stuck in Wichita and he needs to get
home in time for Thanksgiving so let the
roadtrip of frustration begin - a couple
of tweaks now you can see why I said
that movie borrowed a lot from this
movie now in a movie like this seeing
the annoying guy irritate the main
character will drive you to one to two
thoughts I would kill that guy that
remain or whatever that guy had it
coming he is a douche personally in this
movie I think Steve Martin's character
he needed the John Candy experience but
I would kill that guy that were me now
this movie is the prime example of a
movie about two opposite personalities
have a deadline to get across the
country to get the main guy home as he
gets frustrated with the other guy but
the Al Groh in the experience every
other movie can only ever get a silver
medal this is the gold the movies
directed by John Hughes who I mean you
may have heard of the guy he pretty much
had a lot to do with everything awesome
about the 80s
except the hair Steve Martin and John
Candy played their roles perfectly what
I like about John Candy's character is
he's believable he's not just totally
out there granted I wouldn't you like to
drive cross-country with the guy but he
was like believably clinging oblivious
you know he wasn't like Dinner for
Schmucks where you like nobody is that
oblivious like ever nobody is like that
it's just nobody the movies rated R but
it's rated R for one Scene there is one
scene that has the effort in it Steve
Martin just snaps on grace from Ferris
Bueller's Day Off after that the movie
is rated R but let's face it if Mother
Teresa had had the week that Steve
Martin had she would have made the movie
rated R - planes trains and automobiles
is absolutely hilarious there are a
couple of scenes that I laugh to tears
and the movie has hardened it does it
really well a lot better than do
I'm not saying dude a did it horribly or
had no heart I'm just saying planes
trains and automobiles did it better and
sometimes in due date it felt a little
forced still funny movie but you know
and by the end of due date you could not
wait to be free of Zach Galifianakis
just like Robert Downey jr. you just
wanted him gone he's just never going to
talk to the guy again or he's never
going to talk to the guy again
but in planes trains and automobiles
it's a lot more touching than that check
it out for sure I'll be watching it this
Thanksgiving like I have everything's
giving since childhood because planes
trains and automobiles is awesome
tacular how do you rate a classic any
lower than that like impossible and I
hope you all have a fun and festive
Thanksgiving and if you're not American
or you don't celebrate Thanksgiving well
I mean please eat a lot of free [ __ ]
anyway to make us feel good about
ourselves but if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more than click
right here to see more